what you're hearing right now is a
little strange it's the introduction to
Holocene by boney Fair it's the rhythm
of the song played on an instrument that
doesn't normally carry that
responsibility a finger picked acoustic
guitar - acoustic guitars in fact hand
back and forth this hypnotic rhythm is
the first technique of many that Justin
Vernon uses to disorient the listener in
holocene of course you probably don't
feel disoriented it's a disorientation
that Vernon doesn't want you to notice
just like you might not have noticed
that I changed the direction of the snow
I think in fact he wants you to have the
opposite feeling that the song is
inviting you somewhere that feels
strangely like house but to build that
atmosphere that feeling that mood Vernon
has to make you temporarily forget what
you're actually hearing why does he have
to do this well he doesn't have to but
Holocene works really hard to be an
unbreakable piece of art as if the song
was an instrument all itself and to
achieve that feeling Vernon helps us
forget or look beyond the smaller
instruments that make it up it's right
there in the title Holocene comes from
the Greek word Talos which means whole
or entire Paulo scene is also a
geological epoch our current epoch
beginning at the end of the last ice age
and encompassing
all of human culture and history it's
also a bar in Portland Oregon where
Vernon had a pretty shitty knife
these meanings resonate against each
other just like the instruments resonate
off each other and what Vernon is most
interested in is the sound of that
resonance structurally holocene is is
pretty straightforward running for just
over five and a half minutes it begins
with the intro then goes verse-chorus
verse-chorus verse-chorus without a
bridge leading to a pretty abrupt ending
tension is built up and released
throughout the song by the addition and
subtraction of layers of instrumentation
in the intro vernon brings in a slide
guitar for example after the first verse
he brings in the vibraphone a shaker and
what sounds like some hands clapping in
the second verse we get a little more
thrust with the drum kit that's set
pretty far back in the mix actually
which is another thing that Vernon does
repeatedly in this song in the second
course he has brass instruments like
tenor sax trumpets French horn needling
at the bottom of the mix these are
instruments known for their statements
here they become atmospheric
contributors to the overall sound on the
vocals too there are a couple of
harmonies echoing Auburn's main melodic
falsetto but they're low twining like
ghosts around and already ghostly
performance
what tensions been built up subsides for
the third verse as the vocal harmonies
fall away as well as all the instruments
but the wandering brass section which
sounds like the jagged vacants that
Vernon's been citing in the chorus even
the acoustic guitars that have guided
the listener through the song are absent
vernon is playing clarity and confusion
against each other searching still for
that resonance lyrically the song
grapples with insignificance love family
but it filters these things through the
prism of memory an undulating memory
again Vernon is less interested in each
individual image than he is in the sea
that brings them forth he's interested
in the mind as a phenomenon why it
forgets so much hollows out so much and
delivers sudden moments of epiphany and
vision
the song finds its full expression in
the final chorus an expression of the
mood it's created and the memories it's
trying to evoke I think this hits so
hard because the truth is that memories
are a mood the mind is made out of
language but it's not always or even
usually lucid language mostly it's a
vast reservoir of gibberish here and
there a concrete image leaps to the
front a moment seemingly at random maybe
it happened maybe not exactly that way
as a favorite writer once put it memory
commits you to the nuance the fog if you
act on memory you commit yourself on the
basis of echoes no basis on which to
inch out across your life and yet all
you have holocene is an attempt to map
the contours of that nuance and I think
it succeeds beautifully and even though
I know they are specifically the
contours of Vernon's life somehow I feel
close to the terrain as if the
uniqueness of his own revelation unlocks
something universal some way a part of
me a part from
there is a new nerdwriter video every
wednesday so if you go right there and
click on that box you'll subscribe and
get all the videos and that's what helps
me out the most thanks so much for
watching this I have a blast making all
of these and I'm really grateful I'll
see you guys next Wednesday